alors la liberté d'expression est elle
finalement menacé sur les réseaux
sociaux les géants du web sont ils des
censeurs pour en débattre à nous ça nous
avec florian philippot président du
parti des patriotes bonsoir florian
philippot merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés julie garnier oratrice nationale
de la france insoumise bon se croire
avoue julie garnier merci d'être là
également on l'a entendue dans le sujet
au total 400 marques et pas les moindres
qui ont décidé de cesser leurs
publicités pour protester notamment
contre facebook puisque c'est ce réseau
social qui est visée clairement qui est
jugé trop tolérants envers les prises de
paroles racistes insultante ou violente
c'est votre avis à vous aussi julie
garnier il fallait stopper facebook qui
est beaucoup trop tolérant je crois
qu'on pose pas le sujet de la bonne
façon
concernant facebook et puis là vous
parlez d'une histoire qui se passe aux
etats unis aux états unis vous voyez
qu'on attend du gaffard de facebook
entre autres de faire la justice moi je
ne pense pas que ce soit aux gaffes à de
faire la justice je pense que c'est à la
justice de faire la justice en france on
a eu un peu le même équivalent avec la
loi à bien vous savez qu'il était
d'ailleurs retoqué parce que ce n'est
pas aux gars pas à facebook à twitter et
c'est de dire ce qui peut être dit ou ce
qu'il peut pas pour ça on a des choses
qui s'appelle des lois et ce sont des
lois républicaines et uniquement la
justice républicaine
peut être peut dire ce qui peut dit et
ce qu'il ne peut pas affectivement
pardonnez moi je vous ai couvert par ce
qu'on vous vous disiez ça se passe aux
etats-unis mais c'est beaucoup de
marques européennes qui sont en train de
couper les publicités donc ce n'est pas
un problème purement américain ça
concerne notamment facebook france pour
la france donc ça prend de l'ampleur
florian philippon ne prend pas le
problème dans le bon sens vous trouviez
vous
en tout cas facebook trop tolérant c'est
le seul réseau social qui par exemple ne
censure pas donald trump en tout cas ne
note pas des remarques sur ses sweats
par exemple contrairement aux autres
réseaux sociaux
non mais attendez là on parle de
multinationale nike coca cola etc
vous pensez qu'elles ont quelque chose à
faire honnêtement des propos haineux lés
propos racistes c'est évidemment un coup
de pub c'est évidemment la pression des
concurrents qui fait que chacun n'a plus
le choix se sentent obligés d'annoncer
qu'ils vont répartir cette opération de
suppression de publicité sur facebook
sur les réseaux sociaux et c'est mark
l'a donc strictement rien à faire de
tout cela elles sont juste là pour faire
de l'argent et elle ferait mieux
d'ailleurs de s'intéresser à la manière
dont elles traitent leurs salariés dans
l'âme à nantes elle exploite des gens
des enfants dans leurs usines du tiers
monde parce que pendant qu'on parle de
cet internat elle s'achète une bonne
conscience à peu de frais et ça leur
permet de continuer leur sale boulot
environnementales sociales et compliqué
contre certains enfants ou des who do
you des personnes maltraitées dans le
tiers monde il ya beaucoup de rapports
des ong l'etics ou d'étiquettes par
exemple plus qu'à pointer du doigt nike
en 2018 et tant d'autres où adidas et
donc franchement moi je n'attends pas de
ces boîtes place pour que c'est
extrêmement dangereux que c'est moi tu
n'as s'érigent en justiciers de la
liberté d'expression quant à la sphère
de donald trump
twitter a déjà un modéré plusieurs fois
ses tweets moi je suis désolé qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas avec donald trump lui
l'élu il est chef d'état
les présidents d'une démocratie que
chacun des états unis un réseau social
privé se permettent ils ont des critères
ou des algorithmes de bidouiller de
modérer la parole d'une personnalité
élue d'un chef d'état je trouve que
c'est une dérive grave estime quoi qu'on
pense encore une fois de n'importe
quelle déclaration de n'importe quel
chef d'état élu démocratiquement
je trouve que c'est extrêmement va
préoccupant mais ça doit tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé chez tous ceux qui
défendent la liberté d'expression et
bien tout simplement la démocratie julie
garnier est ce que vous partagez le
diagnostic de florian philippot alors on
précise que ce ne sont pas que des
grosses multinationales américaines le
danois lego a rejoint ses autres marques
coca unis
il yal européen volkswagen qui a
également coupé ses budgets aujourd'hui
l'oréal
il ya quelques jours on en parle et
voilà alors ça c'est un autre débat mais
c'est vrai que là on supprime le côté
blanchissement blanc sur ces produits
selon-vous julie garnier à ce que ses
marques la halle cède à une forme tout
même de de pression vous n'avez pas
cette lecture je crois que l'enjeu ni va
au delà de 6 marques savez la censure
sur les réseaux sociaux il existe et
nombre de concitoyens ressentent une
véritable censure sur les réseaux et on
peut dire que le climat leur donne
plutôt raison voit que déjà que la
liberté en général est attaqué je pense
à la liberté manifesté à la liberté et
exprimé je vous rappellerai quand même
que pendant le confinement une femme a
eu droit à une garde à vue juste pour
avoir mis en kart macro navires us à sa
fenêtre donc vous voyez que les libertés
elles sont fortement attaquées quand
même et il faut s'en inquiéter
mais j'ai envie de regarder de manière
c'est un peu plus large c'est à dire
qu'elles sont attaquées par notamment
une certaine pensée une certaine
oligarchie dominante qui voit dans ces
réseaux sociaux et finalement
l'opportunité pour bon nombre de
citoyens de pouvoir s'exprimer et de
pouvoir trouver une information qui ne
trouvent pas sur les médias dominants
elie peut-être là le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a des médias dominants
qui sont sus truc structuré qui est
structurant et qui donne une influence
sur ce qu'on doit penser ce qu'on doit
pas penser et c'est peut-être ça aussi
le souci qu'il faudrait souligner et je
pense notamment à certains censure qui
existent sur les médias je ne citerai
que quelques exemples mais pour
illustrer le propos je vous rappelle
quand même qu'une enquête sur crédit
mutuel avait été censuré par bolloré
qu'une autre enquête sur la vienne elle
avait été censurée sur m6 donc vous
voyez que il y à des censures qui existe
et je trouve que dans ces réseaux
sociaux quand on veut les attaquer j'y
vois une certaine façon de mettre de
côté finalement une pensée va la pensée
des citoyens la pensée du peuple et ça
c'est plutôt inquiétant une certaine but
des classes finalement où on voit une
oligarchie dominante des bourgeois
dominant qui veulent pas dire ce que les
autres doivent penser c'est plus
compliqué avec les réseaux ciation en
tous les cas facebook 1
ça a obtempéré si j'ose dire parce qu'il
a commencé à durcir le ton aujourd'hui
un vrai changement
le réseau social a banni google ou à une
mouvance violents d'extrême droite de
son réseau fermé 220 compte au contenu
haineux florian philippot votre réaction
à la réaction facebook les autres mais
écoutez vous savez les citoyens ils
iront ils iront à inventer autre chose
et iron eyes are voilà tout simplement
et on va se retrouver finalement être
tous sur des réseaux peut être qu'à la
fin on sera tous sur des réseaux russes
chinois ou peut-être même nord-coréens
ont sais pas ils sont peut-être un jour
plus libre que nos propres réseaux des
soi disant démocraties occidentales qui
sont en train de devenir la véritable
enfer qu'est ce que c'est que cette ces
pays dans lesquels on vit on a plus loin
de rien dit on à le droit de rien penser
on n'a plus droit de alors on sait pas
ce qu'on va vexé une telle ou telle
minorité agissante et plein de haine et
pleines de ressentiment qui peuvent vous
envoyer devant la justice à tout moment
si elle estime qu'un amour que vous
auriez dit ne lui a pas plu il aurait pu
aurait pu vexer la pensée de ses
ancêtres il ya 500 ans
qu'est ce que c'est que cette société
complètement dingue où on supprime le
démo ou l'oréal supprime le l'adjectif
clair vous imaginez on nous aurait dit
ça il ya dix ans l'aurait pas cru on
n'aurait pas coûté non c'est stupide
on est plus à l'oréal là on est dans un
état de 6 cas trick on déboulonne des
statuts nous on agresse c'est cette nuit
de de gaulle et on écrit dessus et smara
gist de gaulle esclavagiste par faut
être cinglé souhaite on sait que le
niveau de culture générale s'est
effondrée dans notre pays dans nos pays
occidentaux que notre occident et en
détenait un manifeste et on est en train
de le prouver mais quand même
donc là on s'attaque à la liberté
d'expression on s'attaquait la liberté
penser à la conscience des hommes et des
femmes
c'est gravissime et tout ça par des
boîtes qui sont là pour faire du fric et
qui sont là pour nous octroyer quand
elles le souhaitent un peu de liberté et
nous a retiré quand elles le souhaitent
également sans jamais que la justice ni
l'état de droit ne puisse s'exprimer
moi je trouve ça fera le plus grave
c'est que les états et les soi disant
démocratie comme la france accompagne le
mouvement inscrit effectivement s'il n'y
avait pas eu de la censure du conseil
constitutionnel
dès aujourd'hui le 1er juillet on aurait
appliqué l'odieux loi via c'est à dire
qu'on aurait tous eu des gros boutons
quand on serait allé sur twitter
facebook ou youtube on aurait pu
dénoncer le voisin dénoncer telle ou
telle vidéo pour la faire supprimer dans
les 24 heures
c'est ça ce que nous promettait le
un moment maintenant il accompagne en
réalité facebook et tous les censeurs
ben moi je trouve ça grave je pense
qu'il faut beaucoup plus de liberté il
ya beaucoup plus d'intelligence matière
plus de liberté oui quand il ya plus de
liberté peut aussi à des sottises voir
des horreurs mais il peut y avoir et il
y aura aussi plus d'intelligence par
contre quand il ya plus de libertés et
quand il n'ya plus que de la censure
vous pouvez être certain qu'il n'ya plus
que de la bêtise et il n'y a plus rien
d'intelligent qui se dit dans ce monde
je les gardais vous voyez sourire et
agir prendre des notes
non les justes monsieur philippe on
oublie un peu l'histoire en fait le fait
de déboulonner les statues de débaptiser
des rues ça se fait pendant toute
l'histoire en fait et ça c'est
l'historienne qui vous parle c'est à
dire que l'histoire et la mémoire est
quelque chose qui se rend visite à
chaque fois d'ailleurs sa porte mais
maman c'est une science ça s'appelle
historiographie voilà donc l'histoire
elle se réécrit et c'est logique c'est
même sein de pouvoir revoir les mémoires
il sait ça se fait voilà ça fait vous
savez que tous les ans des bâtisses des
rues et ça ne choque absolument personne
par contre il faut pas non plus être
mélangés malheureusement on voit aussi
qu'il y a une certaine parole qui se
libèrent et là je pense notamment un
chroniqueur que vous devez peut-être
bien connaître monsieur zemmour qui qui
est régulièrement tous les jours sur sur
une chaîne de grande ampleur quand même
et qui peut déblatérer sas et ses
horreurs sans que personne ne lui dit
absolument rien ça aussi c'est une c'est
une c'est une catastrophe parce que
quelque part le débat n'est pas posée de
manière sereine
on voit que quelqu'un qui a été condamné
plusieurs fois pour incitation à la
haine
aujourd'hui peut trouver une tribune
facile et ça je trouve aussi que c'est
un souci et je pense que je vous le
disais en préambule je crois que c'est
là dessus qu'il faut insister seule la
justice peut dire on s'arrête et où
commence la liberté d'expression on a
les lois elles sont faites pour ça et
aujourd'hui si elle ne s'applique pas
c'est justement parce qu'on manque de
justice et je parle des citoyens
réclament ça en prenait lui de la
justice du débat serein de la démocratie
et aujourd'hui on constate qu'on en
manque cruellement
et c'est pour ça peut-être que les
débats se chauffe alors qu'ils ne le
devraient pas parce que les conditions
démocratiques tout simplement ne sont
pas réunies ce n'est pas le mot de la
fin est votre réponse à à julie garnier
de sujets
le nonce un choc déroulement des statuts
vous dites ça s'est toujours fait dans
ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'historiographie ce sont des cinglés
qui se permet de jeter de la peinture
sur les statues du général de gaulle le
général de gaulle j'espère que vous
savez qui c'est c'est celui qui nous a
qui a fait l'appel du 18 juin à la
résistance ils ont jeté des parties mort
contre lui
ils veulent déboulonner tous ces gens là
y compris fédère des conflits schoelcher
et compris colbert et y compris napoléon
ça c'est la haine de la france ça n'a
rien à voir avec l'historiographie ce
sont des voyous qui consacrent leur
place derrière les barreaux de prison
quant à zemmour va les débats contre lui
allez débattre contre lui s'il n'est pas
d'accord mais nous dit pas d'un côté que
vous êtes pour la liberté d'expression
et de l'autre côté deux secondes plus
tard vous appelez à la censure des
révisé moore sur cnued soit celle soyez
cohérents tu as les débattements
autonomie ou si vous n'y allez pas c'est
peut-être que vous avez peur de ne pas
être au niveau
à mon avis le petit modèle fois je vais
les garder et peut-être parce que vous
avez été interpellé maintenant très
rapidement si vous le voulez bien
mercier vos dons juste pour éviter moi
je suis j'étais habitué un petit peu
plus élégant da par messieurs philippot
je pense que juste caricaturer le débat
n'est pas à la hauteur
je voyais c'est de ça dont on a besoin
de vrais débats et de pouvoir poser les
choses là c'est juste historiens qui
vous parlent quant à monsieur zemmour
écoutez si cela ne vous pose aucun
problème que quelqu'un puisse dire que
la couleur verte quel rapport avec
l'islam
moi je pense que ça fait juste remonté
des sombres souvenirs et je vous invite
sérieusement revoir vos cours d'histoire
mais juste on peut le dire mais vous
avez le droit de dire que j'ai pas
d'accord moi je laisse le droit à tout
le monde de dire qu'on est d'accord ou
pas d'accord je demande simplement que
tout le monde ait le droit de parler
vous voyez la différence entre nous moi
je suis pour le débat y compris que vous
ayez un débat acharné avec zemmour n'est
pas que vous censurer les émaux parce
que vous ne l'aimez pas là c'est autre
chose
en tout cas vous avez des batteries pour
les deux voilà pas de pas de censure sur
rtl france vous avez des ventes chez
tous les deux merci à vous deux florian
philippot et julie garnier d'avoir été
avec merci à vous